Olivier Paradis-Lemieux.
- Sans avoir été repêché mais à
force de travail et
d'acharnement, Chris Boucher et
Lugentz Dort en fait leur place
dans la plus grande ligne du
monde : la NBA.
- Veuillez accueillir monsieur
Lugentz Dort et monsieur Chris
Boucher!
- Des modèles de persévérance
pour la députée de Bourassa-
Sauvé, Paule Robitaille, qui
tenait à leur remettre
la médaille de l'Assemblée
nationale à l'école secondaire
Calixa-Lavallée après une année
éprouvante particulièrement pour
les jeunes du quartier.
PAULE ROBITAILLE, députée,
PLQ, Bourassa-Sauvé
- On était dans l'oeil
de la tempête, ça été tellement
difficile pour nos jeunes,
en particulier ici. Alors
la moindre des choses, c'était
de leur amener Luguentz puis
Chris pour qu'ils parlent.
Pour qu'ils leur parlent puis
qu'ils leur donnent un petit peu
d'espoir.
- Chris Boucher et Lugentz Dort
ont grandi dans des familles
modestes du quartier et ont eu
un parcours scolaire cahoteux
aujourd'hui multimillionnaire il
martelait l'importance de
s'accrocher à l'école surtout
quand on cherche encore son but
dans la vie.
CHRIS BOUCHER,
Raptors de Toronto
- J'étais le long qui ne sert
à rien. Je veux que vous, ça
rentre dans vos têtes que c'est
possible. Si moi je l'ai fait,
si Luguentz l'a fait,
c'est possible.
LUGUENTZ DORT,
Thunder d'Oklahoma City
- Des fois il y a mieux,
des fois il y a pire.
Mais chaque personne à
leur propre parcours, mais moi,
je veux vraiment exprimer
mon parcours parce que,
you know, c'était
vraiment difficile.
FABRICE VIL,
fondateur Pour 3 points
- C'est un message que
les intervenants, les parents
passent souvent; sauf que
d'avoir une célébrité,
une inspiration qui passe
ce message-là, bien ça renforce
encore une fois le message qui
est similaire à ce que les gens
du milieu scolaire ou du milieu
communautaire pensent.
Donc, d'avoir des célébrités qui
passent ce message-là, il est
important. Moi, je pense qu'ils
les aiment énormément.
- Chris Boucher et Lugentz Dort
sont deux des trois Québécois de
la NBA, mais ils sont convaincus
qu'ils seront rapidement rejoint
par d'autres surtout si on
améliore l'encadrement du talent
local.
- Quand je regarde aux États-
Unis, c'est vrai qu'ils ont
les ressources, puis tout,
mais on a le talent ici.
Le talent, il faut qu'il sorte
du Québec, mais il faut avoir
les ressources et ça commence
maintenant.
- Déjà, un autre talent de
Montréal-Nord frappe au port de
la NBA : Bennedict Mathurin
pourrait être repêché dès le
premier tour en juin prochain.
Ici Olivier Paradis-Lemieux,
Radio-Canada, Montréal-No